so just to be clear I'm not talking
about data you explicitly asked me to
talk about something else so we use
pipes and for lots of things and I will
just give you the link at some point
where you can find this notebook and do
some data analysis but I will talk about
the instrument so it's going to be
different what it's interesting before
we start so I'm doing a lot of outreach
talks these days as you can imagine so
we usually go to schools and science
fairs and we want to have especially the
kids to take something home and then
show their family and friends so we
started to develop some apps because
that's what kids one Noah days and I
want you actually to do this now
yourself so that's a free up it doesn't
have any ads doesn't track you doesn't
collect any data so it's very safe so if
you download that thing on an android or
iphone it doesn't very much so it's very
simple it just as a webcam or both of
them and then you see a black hole that
you can move around so if i switch the
camera then i can just do that with you
guys and then you take a picture and you
tweet it okay and then you might win one
of these prizes so that's a good h
indicator for the audience when i do
this with the 50 year old nothing
happens if i do this with kids is
amazing so let's see how how you do okay
so you have 40 minutes to get this
download it and start taking pictures
okay so why am I here so I work for the
lag of project and we have been in the
news so earlier this year that was in
the 12th of februari so this is the date
of the event but these newspaper front
pages are from the 12th of February's so
we've been on the front page with the
science project almost everywhere on the
planet that's a bit unusual why was that
while on that day we published a
research paper and this is it so that's
in physical review letters one of the
better journals and it's about the first
detection of gravitation way so people
thought that's great amazing and
important and
I would like to tell you a little bit
about that today so I have two parts of
the torque in the first part I will just
talk about the instrument in the
detection itself give you a bit of
physics and in the second part I'll talk
a bit about the modeling simulations and
there's a bit of pison in there to keep
it relevant so it's about astronomy we
wanted to astronomy and I need to
explain this a little bit about what
this is and what we want to do most
people have this kind of picture in mind
when you hear astronomy so people
staring through a telescope that's not
quite the state of the art anymore so
for a while we have bigger projects 044
you know on one hand it means fancier
pictures like this one and on the other
hand means everybody just sit there
typing computers so if you become an
astronomer you're not looking through
anything you're just staring at your
computer as everybody else okay so
that's what I try to do when I do they
kind of stem talks to get people into
science you know I mean so the Hubble
telescope is well known and that is
because we want to see more you know and
resume in and understand what it is so
if you see the night sky there are some
things like the moon and planets but
most of these little white dots or
something else so what do you what do
you think what these white dots are okay
second so what what do we see stars okay
so most of the things that are twinkling
up there in the sky are stars well not
not really so if you if you zoom in with
Hubble's and you you can only look at
one particular small thing it's like a
zoom lens so if you zoom it in on this
one that's the extreme deep field photo
that is very famous and then you see in
the patch before there was not much to
see anywhere just a few dots and each of
these dots is not a star and I was a
million of stars in a galaxy or cluster
or something similar so yeah there are
stars all the light comes from stars but
they're much more out there than you
would think so each little dot that you
see as typically not a star so we've
learned a lot use
these instruments but you need to find
out more and especially about the
structure of the universe how it evolved
from the Big Bang to now there is a
couple of gaps in our theory so most of
the stuff we see is stars so have you
ever thought about life and death of the
star except from Death Star so for most
for most people stars are just there I
mean an hour time span on the human time
span just starts don't do very much
they're just there but on a cosmic time
scale that's completely different they
are born they each get fat and then die
and depending on the initial Mars their
age is very different so small stars
like our Sun last a very long time but
large and heavy stars burn very quickly
and then explore quickly and leave
behind typically some nebulae from which
you can form another star but they also
leave behind corpses so most of them end
up having a very dense heavy object left
behind which is not bright so neutron
stars or black holes are the things that
I'm going to talk about in a second so
throughout this talk I would like to
give you some sense of the scale
physical scale of things because that in
physics is quite normal but I don't know
whether everybody appreciates the scale
so let's start with the star the one we
know is our son is a gigantic fireball
so it's not a normal fire it's a plasma
fire but it's just a ball of gas that's
burning and it's about a hundred times
the size of the Earth's and three
hundred thousand times the Mars of years
well that doesn't sound so impressive
hundred times larger yeah but if you
show the picture you know that's earth
the little one is the moon and that's
the Sun so we're not that close so that
we otherwise we would be burnt very
crisp but i just want to show you how
large it is so keep in mind a star is
massive is huge and very heavy so if the
star at the end of its life is heavier
than the Sun so the Sun would not
collapse into a dark corpse like a black
hole if you're a little bit larger so
1.5 times that you would collapse
two neutron star or black hole so then
all these mass just gets compressed very
very much so this is the size of
something that used to be a little bit
larger than the Sun in the form of the
neutron star so for comparison so that's
where I live as a 10-kilometer radius in
Birmingham so the entire huge fireball
gets compressed into something which is
just 10 kilometer wide if it's a neutron
star and if it were trying to black hole
a little bit more so who have you have
seen the movie interstellar we're going
to show your experts on black holes
because that is not from the movie but
this is a proper science simulation I
can tell you that before that movie came
out nobody would have shown a black hole
like this now all scientists show black
holes like this and this is because the
movie shown it like this so this is a
black hole and there's an accretion disk
around it which glows because it's just
gas getting hot and the light bending of
the black hole makes it kind of funny
funny shape by the way one of the the
persons who probably wins the Nobel
Prize for detecting gravitational wave
his Kip Thorne from Caltech and he wrote
the original screenplay for interstellar
just you know so what would a black
holes we don't really know so they are
basically things we can't see what we
mean by black hole is that everything
has crunched together so much that
nothing can escape the black hole that
means also no lights and no signal which
means we don't know what a black hole
actually is except that we can't see it
okay so the name comes from the fact
that if you would look in the sky and
there's a black hole somewhere there's a
black hole in your picture you can't see
what's behind okay how do we know these
exists so mostly we know it from theory
but there is some evidence so this is a
movie you see a years running up there
and this is looking into the center of
our galaxy and trekking over many years
the positions of stars so an astronomer
sitting down you know writing down the x
and y coordinates of the stars for more
than 10 years and then you can make this
plot and then you see they're doing
orbitz trajectories around the center in
which we don't see very much and then
from the orbital mechanics you can
actually compute what should be in the
center and you know it's must be very
heavy and very compact and the only
thing we know that could do that is a
black hole well that's not very
satisfying that's the kind of evidence
we have for black holes this is one of
these supermassive black holes in the
center of galaxies and there are some
other evidence from x-ray observations
for smaller ones but they all indirect
so what we would like to do is see them
directly and there's one way you might
have heard of Einstein and all his
successors yes so he's usually known for
e equals MC squared that's not his most
famous thing by the way we got the Nobel
Prize for something really different but
he wrote something about 100 years ago
101 years exactly now and here I can use
my German so it's called The Goon de la
guarda agyeman relativity it's too early
and this is the the new theory of
gravity general relativity in which he
he brought on new equations ok the
equations are it but we try to imagine
that with this kind of picture that
space gets curved so a mass into space
curves the space and a curved space
affect the other mass ok and that's what
this picture should show if you believe
that so that's just a kind of picture
but it explains it quite well then
imagine when you had two very heavy
things just circling each other like two
black holes orbiting around then they
would change these bends is space-time
and this bending would be rapidly
changing so this changes is kind of
gravitational field in space-time so
strongly that this distortions ripples
away through space itself so that's what
we call a gravitation wave and that
comes purely as a prediction out of
Einstein's theory of gravity so what we
would like to do is to learn more about
dark compact objects to do astronomy ok
because most of these stars or millions
of millions of millions all end up as
something dark and compact
we cannot see to understand how the
universe evolves we need to know more
about the things we want to see them
directly and not just by some evidence
but have signals directly and we could
do that with gravitation ways so what we
want to do is gravitational wave
astronomy and for that we need a
different instrument because they are
not light so you can't take a picture we
need a different instrument to detect
those so the question is then obviously
how do you detect gravitational waves
what do they do so imagine there's a
gravitational wave just coming through
this screen and then you put some what
we call test particles or something in a
in a circle here there are many just
stuck behind and what the gravitation
wave would do is take the circle of
masses and would squash it and stretch
it and this kind of form okay it's a
wave that's passing through and when it
passes through changes the distance
between objects so I'd really have to
imagine that in space a free-floating
they're not you know bolted to the floor
and then these masses would change
position so to measure a gravitation
wave you would have to measure distance
and ideally you would compare these two
distances because one gets longer the
other gets shorter and vice versa so we
need a new telescope which doesn't take
pictures of light but measures a
distance so there are some instruments
to measure length so the easiest one is
to stick a meter stick and measure it
but if you've read puppy public magazine
articles about Einstein you know that's
not the way to do it in the theory of
relativity there's only one way to
measure distances and that is by timing
a photo so I don't want to completely
explain it now so go back to Scientific
American or something they explained it
quite nicely that comes from the idea
that nothing is uniquely at the same
time or simultaneous but everything is
relative relativity and so from there
with some arguments you measure length
only with light pulses so you can buy
one of these and wikipedia tells you
they have an accuracy of millimeters is
quite nice you know for renovating a
kitchen in
and this is good enough we need
something slightly better but we need to
use the same trick timing light pulse so
there's an instrument for that which is
called interferometer so here we have
the two lengths we want to measure and
what we do is we take a light beam
shining it in and splitting it so that
it goes through the two lengths that we
want to measure these black things
should be mirrors that reflect the light
back it comes to the center beam
splitter and he combines and is detected
by a photo detector so what we do here
is take light and just use the light
itself as a as a reference so we sent
them both along these arms and come back
and then compare the time they've taken
because with light you can do
interference so if you if you compare
two of these light beams when they are
coming at the same time the output will
be bright and if you change the timing a
little bit the output becomes dark so
that is just the same thing but more
accurate because you don't need to clock
you use the light itself as a timing
reference well that's an old thing that
was invented in 1887 by a person called
my cousin then we still call this the
Michelson interferometer so there's a
mock-up of his original version and it's
interesting just to see what you could
do with an oil lamp some mirrors
metallic mirrors at the time and the
photo detector was his eye so he was
staring into the thing and then waiting
for the output to change brightness and
then we call this complete change one
fringe and then you had to kind of see
how how little brightness you can you
know just judge by I where I've got a
little bit dark a little bit brighter
and my cousin thought he could do a
percent of this range just by eye and
that's what he that's a famous
experiment actually it's called
Michelson Morley and that is actually
the precursor for this Einstein theory
as they wanted to test whether he is
something called ether that's carrying
light so from this experiment that they
didn't find the ISA was the first steps
towards that the speed of light is
always constant which is what I've done
used for his theory
anyway we just want the instrument to
measure something like that now again to
length scales so in physics we throw out
these numbers 10 to the minus 20 and 10
to the 10 quite easily and they have all
those names but again I would like to
get a little bit of appreciation about
what these mean so I have these six
pictures from one picture to the next
it's always a factor of thousand down we
start with the meteors easy everybody
knows the meter well you're Britain you
know feat but my meter then you go a
factor a thousand down you have
millimeter that's again easy you can
still see it a factor of thousand dong
it's a bit more complicated so what does
this stand for micrometer well that's a
micron here's a factor thousand down
from a millimeter that you can't see
anymore but you can go to being human by
so-called micrometers crew and that is
something while you put something in the
middle and then you screw it together
and then you can measure it thickness
down to a micrometer so that's very nice
so usually when I do this with schools
they don't know this one and they don't
know this one but they all know not a
meter has it's very famous I can do
nanotechnology and that shows at the
moment here just funny examples of virus
in a cage so that's on a nanometer level
factor thousand-dollar from a micrometer
and that's definitely not something we
can see you need special instruments for
it if I go down another factor I got to
p.m. what does that stand for pick a
meter so that's the last picture i can
give you that our two atoms sitting next
to it next to each other that's not a
normal picture of the sea but a special
microscope used to that so on the pica
major scale you down to single atoms and
when you go down one more you're
tempting meters what could that be yes
the femtometer but what could these red
dot probably be
a proton yes so from an atom which is a
some core with electrons around it you
go just to the core as a factor of
thousand remember atoms are empty space
with electrons flying around and in the
middle there is a small cause oh that's
empty meat ok and then that is his
length scale so femtometers here 10 to
the minus 15 nanami to 10 to the minus 9
and so on now let's see what my cousin
could do with his instrument in 1887 so
he could measure down to here
nanotechnology see more than hundred
years old um the question is now what
what do we need you know what what is
required to measure a gravitational wave
is a empty meter for example of what we
want a partially not so gravitational
waves that we expect to change districts
remember we put some master and then we
measure the distance we expect the
lengths change to be you know down here
so that's a bit difficult but we have
two instruments now that can do that so
these are called lago torre what that
means in a second there are two
instruments in the u.s. one in
Livingston Louisiana and one in n thaht
in Washington State and they are micro
interferometer so there are two arms
here they're also two arms so they are
the same kind of intermol interferometer
from its type just a bit better and very
long and they have achieved the
sensitivity of 10 to the minus 20 meters
let's I think million times a million
better than the original my cousin one
and just tell you few words how that
works so like o stands for laser
interferometer gravitational-wave
observatory so that's what we want a
gravitational wave observatory and we
need a micro center for mature to do it
so we have to so they're too large and
24 meters now just show you a few
pictures of one of them and I picked the
hanford side that's a very nice area
that's a former nuclear testing site and
still waste disposal area so if you're
interested in a new job that's very nice
place to go but it's free land where
you can build science projects on
otherwise you have a problem so there's
a central building building here in
which we hold the laser and some of the
optics then there's these long cubes in
which laser beam propagates and there
will be also buildings at the end so if
you go to Googlers and look from there
from the top it looks like this bit dark
if we make that a big bit brighter than
you just see these are roads is central
building and these are the tube so to
give you a sense of scale these things
are four kilometers long so I took
picture of London so thank you [ __ ]
impellers king's cross with someone here
so there's a lot of space they're very
empty so these are huge so they are not
doing very much is just a long arm but
they're very very long now looking at
the arm itself so if you take one of
these elements here and I just show you
a picture for the scale so these are
vacuum tubes so that's just metal tubes
so that you have nothing inside because
the laser beam that travels back and
forth would be distorted by a vibration
so pumped me out you make this size
tubes then at the end of the tunnel so
you get to what we call the end station
it's just small building and at that end
station then you would have a vacuum
tank which is something like this where
the wrong thing you connect that you
okay and if you look inside that now
you're inside the vacuum tanker that's
obviously no vacuum because it people so
you you first have the people in there
and stalling stuff and then when they
are all gone then you pump down and you
get vacuum so there's complicated things
unfortunately don't have time to explain
all this and there is this piece of
glass down here that piece of glass is
the actual mirror okay so that thing we
want to measure how much it moves and we
want to see something that it doesn't
move more than 10 to the minus 19 meter
so all this kind of structure here is to
keep that very quiet and for that I have
to refer to you my next talk so what
happened on the fourteenth of
tember we with these instruments
measured for the first time a
gravitational wave and this is a data
recorder buzzes instrument so the
instruments have basically each one
channel so it's not like cern where are
these terabytes of data flowing out all
the time with one channel assembled at
some tens of kilo Hertz and usually they
don't do much because everything is
quiet and then on that day we saw these
wiggle and we saw the wiggle and the two
instrument so it's one and the other
overlapping exactly right so there your
time shifted by the different arrival
times a few milliseconds till they
overlap exactly these are the models we
get to mine Stein so these are the
predictions from Einstein theory and
here's the residuals if you subtract
those from the data and here's the time
frequency plot where you have on the
x-axis still time and here is just
frequency of the signal and here you see
this shape its chirp so in all these
average dogs we call this a whoop that's
what we were looking for and it was
immediately there okay so no fancy data
people needed okay was just there yay of
course then we have to do a lot of data
analysis to show the significance look
for whether it was a just statistically
you know glitch and all these kind of
things and after all this we published
the result but it was really loud and
clear so what we do from there we
reconstruct what this should have been
and this is the video of it let me just
speed this up a little bit so what you
have here on the bottom it's hard to see
but this is kind of the wiggle in the
data and it becomes blue while we go
through the video to see where the
signal we are and you see the whole
thing happens in a fraction of a second
so we're only going through less than a
second here so these are two black holes
circling around each other just they
have to been doing this for meaning of
year but now they're getting so close
that they were going to crush and this
is the strength the this bottom colorful
plot shows the strength of the
gravitational field if I keep this
running then you see other get closer
and you see this kind of wavy pattern
that already gravitation waves are
leaving
that area of space and when we get
closer to the actual final crushing
merger you see that the signal becomes
stronger and now just just before the
actual event it gets really very crazy
around here this is the most energetic
event in the universe we know of and at
some point the tool just merge it's just
a kind of switch because we don't know
really what happens we just say we
cannot describe them as to anymore we
have to describe them as one and
afterwards we have a single black hole
of which we hear nothing ever after
because it's quiet the only thing that
we can send this is kind of very violent
event in the middle and these waves
going away okay so that's what we've
what we've done in as a kind of funny
compute computer simulation but the
facts so a billion years ago which means
it was a billion light years away at
that ideas distance okay there were two
black holes about 30 36 times our the
mass of our Sun and 29 times the mass of
our Sun then they inspire that means
they get close and then that crash like
form one black hole which is 62 so
there's a few solar masses missing
because you lose that as energy and that
is one of these most violent events you
can already imagine that these kind of
things that are heavy like 60 times our
stars and they're orbiting each other a
200 Hertz means 200 times a second you
know imagine your kitchen blender like
yeah that's a bit bigger okay so that is
really really hard to imagine and what
then happens a billion years later they
wiggle our mirrors well 10 to the minus
80 meters 4.1 seconds okay that's
roughly the timeline and that means i
get talks like this I
when I went a lot of prizes and so on
okay so second part not have to speed up
a little bit because I don't have as
much time as I thought but I would like
to give you a little bit of an insight
about how we beat these things and I'm
working especially on the optics
experimentally and what we do is do an
America simulations for which we use
Python and so on so let me just give you
a few glimpses of that first of all we
are huge collaboration so they thought a
thousand authors currently working on
the project that are on the paper and
these all's it the university is
involved so it's a one of these big
science projects and for the
interferometry what we do is we take the
simple concept that i showed you before
and work on it and this is a kind of
sketch how it looks today there are lots
of things we had to do just show you
what one of the few things that actually
make it better so you get better signal
so longer you get that's why these
things are four kilometer long then a
lot of these things are increasing the
signals increase with laser power so we
ramp up the laser power and that you do
buy better lasers but also by having
what we call optical cavities optical
resonators in which the power increases
and then there's another thing that you
want to do is filter so passive filters
are good to just get noise down and
again you can use optically the same
thing is optically cavities and
resonators well that's why the whole
thing starts to look complicated
unfortunately I can't explain the
details I just want to get across the
sense of complexity that we weird in so
it's getting much better but
unfortunately getting much more complex
and to give you just a sense of what I'm
what I'm missing out most of the work is
actually on each component to make it
not shaking so the mirror especially
needs to be quiet to 10 to the minus 80
meters a vet is the real achievement
okay well I can't talk about that so but
just say because I want to talk about
the optics so this little symbol year
this half circle with a line it's a
standard symbol your useful photo
detector and you can buy photo detector
online for quit that's a photo detector
but what I mean what we mean by this is
obviously just kind of a sub system so
that
photo detector that detector looks like
this so this is the main interferometer
beam and then it goes into up the
mechanics here and more to mechanics
here you see it split into several beans
because we have to optimize how we
detected for its high power we have to
have auxiliary beams for the control and
all this kind of thing so each of these
little symbols in the diagram before is
a huge subsystem so we developed those
over many years so when you start
thinking okay how do I make a better
detector you're here have an idea then
physicist you get out some piece of
paper its a math you know see what the
ideas work and then the key aspects are
these two things tabletop and prototype
tests where you haven't affirmative this
size in my lap of some of these then we
have 10 meter size prototypes to see
whether that idea that you have is
practically doable however that is very
expensive and takes a lot of time so
that in parallel we run code to try to
speed that up to find out especially if
it ideas bad so most of my job is
running simulation saying no no no okay
shoot our ideas quickly so that the ones
that you have to test on an experiment
or fewer okay that's the job optics is
at least for me easy to model because
everything is linear in terms of
equations in math I have some light
fields that are complex numbers then
have some objects that as a black box
but it's linear equations and then I get
some light out and for example all these
optical cavities and resonators I was
talking about those two mirrors facing
each other and then you can write down
you know the sketch then you write down
a set of linear equations you perform
this into a matrix you can source a
matrix and when you solve a matrix were
pretty particular input vector where you
say okay the light comes from there you
get all the fields at every node as an
output so we're just solving a simple
matrix equation you know all the optical
views everywhere also in the output so
that's what you want and to plot
something he would solve this matrix and
you in the parameter a little bit solve
it again you know Jim the parameter sold
again okay so and luckily these forms
base as optical systems form sparse
matrix a matrix that is
pass very similar to a linear circuit so
for that you have obviously a lot of
code available unfortunately we can use
none like they have to write our own
because we need to really adapt it to
our problem so most people that do
modeling do this mistake that they're
either do it like this or like that so
either they want to model everything and
now you have in the computer the real
world and then you stare at the computer
and say well that's complicated don't
understand what is doing okay and then
you just recreated your problem that you
don't understand what it's doing but
that doesn't help you usually also runs
10 times lower than real-time
experiments so it's just worse okay
that's what we've done and luckily
thrown away I think most people went
through this phase then the other one is
you use fundamental concepts only say
okay can reduce the dupe you know first
principles and so on and then you give
it a nice clean elegant math and
everything looks right however that
actually then doesn't reproduce the
problem that you're investigating so
typically something is going wrong with
your experiment and you want to find
what but your model is always perfect
okay so what we need to do is kind of
find the right level of abstraction so
that is not a coding problem there is
not a number crunching you need to write
library no it is this kind of thinking
of how to formulate the problem and
because we built this instrument for the
first time we can ask nobody we just do
it we do it wrong okay we do it again we
do it wrong and we do it and so on so we
are still in a learning process how to
do this right when we actually write and
use our models so that's a good bit the
bad bit is this one so we write our own
code but we are none educated in their
business at all so typically I'm an
experimental physicist I had a problem
and I thought okay I need some code then
I'm writing it myself which then caused
all these problems so I'm my own user
that's good because I know what I want
but I'm the only user typically for a
long time so that doesn't help me
finding bugs then I don't know anything
about coding practices at all but now I
know a little bit but it's ten years
later so the code is awful in all ways
and then my biggest problem was always
this one because real physicists don't
use simulations so you have a serious on
this side that want to understand it
mathematically pure math nothing else
and you have to experimental is on the
other side let's say no I have to see it
working here because it's so easy to
make a plot which what the simulators
doing and everybody has come to these
other two people I'd say of all these
plots i can tell you and later and
realize that the simulator didn't
understand the problem so there's a real
problem getting a team to listen to the
person who did the model so over the
years we got better with that but that i
think is the biggest challenge so I
wrote some code when I was a PhD student
97 and at cincy at that time I didn't
know better it's a lot of code it's open
source when we still use it and actually
lots of people use it that's good
because now I have lots of users as very
simple so what you do is you write in a
text file just some cryptic sin syntax
that are invented one line
one line is a command or component take
your pick then you open up a terminal
and then you type the name of the binary
and that of it of the file and runs and
it produces a text fire as an output
that's it okay that's what my code does
but it writes batch files for a new plot
Matt Lappin pison that you can call and
then get a plot okay so some give a
friendly nursing year so you get a plot
and that's what we want we want very
quick so it takes a second you see I
mean this is really no time at all what
I want is to do this and then I change
your number and I do it again in a
change your number so I want to play
okay that's what we still do I just want
to play no number crunching just play so
now I mean my my software should
actually be only for people that using
laser interferometers at the level of 10
to the minus 20 meter the only 100 of
those on the planet I don't know why I
still get three four thousand downloads
every time they are mostly that truck
actually our project that that is us
there's this is mostly us here in here
and these are two so I kind of guess
where some of these users come from but
I don't know where the others come from
but I get Newton back reports and is
very nice so then around this kind of
see binary that doesn't do much you need
some more some more powerful stuff so we
wanted to write some scripting stuff
around it to automate task pre-processed
data post process data and we started to
doing that in matlab and that was
because the project had decreed MATLAB
is to standard okay and then that was
2006 i wrote a lot of tools to do all
this in matlab and in 2013 I drum chip
and did this again in Python and the
reason was I mean so matlab has been you
know kind of losing some ground we even
within the project and the reason was
not everybody gets a license so you have
a few people in the project that can run
stuff and the others just hmm ok so that
was not really good because it really
limits what you can do with this
software and then most of the scripting
we want to write around is text passing
from for which model apps terrible so we
didn't like that and then you
students coming in they all want to use
poison okay so they'd here are the cool
people coming into Caltech and so now
from the bay area and our project they
all want to use pison and they really
put some pressure on the older guy is
saying we have to use matlab so i got my
easy to do it and you know for me the
main reason why i like it is that
provides you know notice they know the
ability so now it provides the right mix
of stability and still being able to
play with it okay and the outcome is
another set of tools we call packet and
mostly we use it in I applied for
notebooks to run museum of the other
binary and we try to be very slim so we
only use the standard packages that most
scientists use so mostly numpy and some
of the others of the sea so i don't have
much time but i want to show you a quick
example of what we actually do so
usually we run a lot of things for
designing and so on but what is
interesting when you actually have
something already running and when to
find out was wrong so go back in time
very long way when we didn't have money
so way to clone ourselves at that's an
extra control room of an extra
gravitational wave detector about 15
years ago and me couple of times and
what we wanted to see there is a control
signal that looks like this blue line to
control the interferometer so before it
was working but after it was installed
but we got most of the time as a signal
like this and then I started modeling by
comparing what I saw I saw a beam that
looked like this and you know there's a
beam should be round okay everybody
knows that so that was wrong and I coded
in my simulations errors until I got in
my simulation something that was wrong
as well said okay nice but I still
didn't have exactly what i wanted and i
saw this kind of roundness was wobbling
up and down and I then tried to code
that in that is a motion we knew existed
and then is my simulation wobbling the
beam up and down like it looked on my TV
screen in the control room and with that
I could reproduce this and then looked
at the code whatever side to put in to
recreate that and then we went to the
tank open it and fixed it so that's one
of the not too many examples where they
were
me but one of the examples where we
really found through simulation
something quicker and similarly two to
beam shapes these mirrors that are
showing you for this is a corrective
coating on it and this will take enough
later it needs to be very very flat and
these mirrors cause several hundred
thousand dollars so what you want is
that you have some way of testing it
before you hand over the money so when
you buy when you buy the mirrors the
manufacturer gives you measurement of
the surface and then we run the
simulations to actually determine
whether it's good or not and we used my
software to determine whether a logo
pace Amira's or not well I'm fine we
paid nobody so and something you can
have look for yourself that's something
so we do a lot of teaching with these
notebooks now as well so we have run
some schools where everything is I
python-based and just show you the links
so we have this public on github and we
holds the static HTML version on my
webpage because we think in github is
too slow if people want to interact and
click through so we just converted
everything once and upload it to the web
page and just at the end is it good I
think yes so for us it has been a good
experience we got what we need there are
just a few problems with it so
installation is non-trivial so even
though it got better for non-programmers
for non coders for non data scientist is
still a disaster okay and that limits my
use of this because I have to convince
an experimental physicist of what I'm
doing is right and they want to try it
so that's bad at the moment this is this
is on the way up I think it's just
tricky at the moment to sometimes with
the packages two and three and so on and
then there's one thing which is called
simulink in MATLAB that we have no
replacement for which really stops us
because we need this a lot and then if
you actually more interesting data which
i know you are there are stuff so does
two examples of use of pison so one is
Jamie Roland system wrote a nice paper
about distributed state machine to
control the instrument you can find it
on the archive so my slides are on the
weapon
where you can find all these links later
and then they talked about before all
our data is open there's an ipass a
notebook that explains how to do all the
data analysis so and if you want to know
more about Lego there's a very easy way
of doing that there's a magazine like or
magazine which has all the stuff in
there it's a free pdf that comes out
every six months and it's really nice
it's not for you it's for us so it's
full of jargon but the same time means
you can see what we're doing so it's not
PR it's not advertising it's just for us
but you can download and read okay and
was that my time is finally up thank you
very much response let's roll goose that
would really very much really super
excited so we're going to take questions
in just a moment and i'm going to thank
andreas for compressing the talk ever so
slightly so we're running a few minutes
late so by way of admin could the
speakers for the next room please that's
Kieran Frank and Giles and Annabelle go
to your rooms and get set up and then
Marco you're just let the jump on stage
and perform a magic act I guess that
I've really quickly when we come that's
my main bit of OE and everyone checked
the schedule because the online schedule
is a bit different to what it was
yesterday so I'm gonna know the Truman's
you going to be in check the online
schedule and then we'll take a few
minutes of questions and then we'll do a
blooms up so nobody else leave just the
speak oh and a Wi-Fi code to get them
from the front desk they're available on
the front desk so get those wendys left
the room afterwards right over to
andrea's for a couple minutes of
questions do we have any questions from
dress so the two instruments you said
there's a light rail that's one between
the two is there actually a light pipe
between the toe and is your cable wires
feel really big for the fiber you've
written from them
yeah yeah saw the question well to
rephrase the question why are there two
instruments and is a connection between
them I said yeah so I didn't really say
that we need to because and
gravitational wave detector is like a
microphone so you only really just hear
a song but you don't know we're coming
from so you need to to do like something
like serious on to triangulate but also
because we do it for the first time that
was the first ever detection we need to
convince people that what we're doing is
right so how do can you distinguish that
somebody just kicked your tank or it was
a gravitation wave so you do two of them
and then monitoring the environment very
carefully so that you can compare the
two and do a correlation analysis so no
there's no connection between the two
except that with time stamp with GPS
data what we do in both sides yes we
didn't we didn't point so the question
was how do we know that the black holes
were from extra from there from the
southern hemisphere and how it could be
point our detectors in this way we
didn't so we omnidirectional and we're
just hoping that something happened so
we we believe some event like this on
this strange happens once a month we
just didn't have the detector to measure
it so we believe from now on so at the
moment we're again in maintenance mode
because we've just switched on which
they're working on the detector when we
believe this one will be just coming
from all over the sky and we're just
monitoring the entire sky
yeah they're our future detectors yes so
the question was for future detectives
whether we can do something longer ago
on Mars and so on so what I was talking
about was one type of detector there are
others in the planning so one is
space-based 50 kilometer 50 million
kilometer long as we don't go on a
planet because it's noisy each planet is
noisy you go away from planets to go
into space and this mission is going to
go to different frequency so it's like
different telescopes we don't actually
compete but we just feel different slots
so that's in the works and they're also
using normal telescopes radio telescopes
to do even larger ones where the noise
requirements all different for each of
these but yeah that's in the works
yes other question was oh there was a
statement that it was bit by chance
because when we switched on we
immediately saw something and how often
does it happen that's true we we
actually saw this before we switch to
science mode that was amazing so we were
ready for the next day and when the
signal came we detected it before but
that's because since we run la go since
2000 I'm just upgrading it steadily
whenever we go home with which to
science mode so even though we were
officially waiting to start assigns run
you know we were always in science mode
to some extent how often does that
happen so we increase the sensitivity
all the time so we believe it happens
all the time we just now reached the
threshold where we can see them and as I
said I think we this one will be once a
month roughly so we've seen one we've
seen one we are still analyzing the data
for a second bit of data which we will
publish in a month from now and I can't
tell you more about that then we had
maintenance mode at the moment and we're
going to start the next sector size 10
is better sensitivity in a month or two
and this goes on for another three years
until we reach the design sensitivity
and then run continuously and what I'm
talking about the rates is the final one
so in three years we think we're just
running and we get continuous signals
every month
you